now I was gonna say your name so for
these matches have been bellissimo
Oh God they've been so good but there's
more verses I musician that's what I've
taught me look for the eyes the max of
it just is good but here we go
yes Pakistan vs. Korea on this love you
burst onto the scene in his first ever
international tour Tokyo Masters taking
the win without breaking a sweat
he is here now the LCQ trying to get
that last spot or tomorrow's finals man
well I would say I would ask you who you
want to win well shirts don't you don't
need to us bro hey looking at all these
players that we have here that are left
in our top eight men any one of these
guys yes
well I feel like any one of these guys
will do well tomorrow but man only one
of them can make it through that's the
way it works man that's definitely the
way it works but here we go
um my musician has been scaring the hell
out of me all day we can watch him from
up there and I'm just like man how do
you deal with well I was told by the
Koreans when I was there they said look
if you haven't played a musician for for
the first time your plane is gonna [ __ ]
you up
we're gonna see we're gonna see what
kind of stress he has against Akuma yes
so let's see what he got my musician is
already eliminated here now so I'm
guessing articles talk to ever see like
what what kind of tendencies he has let
me guess the download and in the lower
part of our Yoshi mr. right saying like
trying to point out how yo she met some
tendency yeah first the players of that
so many different tricks
oh my god the tricks right now silly
rabbit
follow up here let see what he does he's
looking at the jumping wow what a jump
it Todd hey you know actually before a
season 3 this is this matchup for Akuma
was a little tough even if you hit back
more ninjas even for that we would never
hit the one event the three would know
Chelsea yeah it was
very very hard to land it on using
sometimes impossible sometimes right
5050 at the end day off to part with a
bus route you know you should move tool
or wise one of his swords is a demon
slaying sword are you trying to that's
DLC what's easy for DLC to catechu my
bad
alright the follow up here old Knights
step out of there can I pull all that
work swept away sweep the leg Johnny I
know if you were to take all the damage
that I've used to see this done to
himself drops a tighter he's eliminated
self like four times he is a triple
again he's gone
let's see what he does nice get the hit
you need that but now he's gonna really
start to have like take some advantage
here the matchup right
oh well you want the flash again yeah
it's just a little out of range ball up
I'd do it again
meds like down for oh yeah Oh keeping
him out with a five holes now should it
oh wait [ __ ] listen to me you should be
able to get in here into the range are
nice he knew he was gonna get the wall
break closes is that house yeah
we got more games to write first time
fighting yes but are you is this the
first game he did say the first game you
never know this guy might have a crazy
adjust ability I mean the team blood is
definitely one of those guys I look and
I'm like speak it at any point in time
you can turn it around
of course I mean he's played the best
character for it oh okay what's a mix of
oh you went for the low that size bit to
it oh yeah y-coordinate oh if I try [ __ ]
buddies I like you my god
yo yes be careful though because oh
please
with the resents were using for your
high but like I don't like that music
for us you know not your old buddy oh my
god this is Luther brought you guys
ladies Atlanta loser this is going home
that was crazy tell us four tickets left
on the lab like five the ten-second I
was like what's gonna have the defense
of my musician day man it's messed up
because it feels like the people that
are left in deserve to be in this tops
morale tomorrow yeah but only one of
them are yeah I feel bad for everyone
like a second place ever
yeah he's not gonna be in the state's
second place he's not here the Reno feel
like a place of too many times oh the
big counter in sidekick here here's the
follow-up he's definitely gonna push
towards the wall
oh that's to be launched yes sir here oh
oh it's a type kick good about reward
about there yeah it's close enough right
look at that probably picking his head
he's played me for the first time you
don't don't know this just going through
his bow jaws like hey he's starting to
do it look at it right now yeah off to a
huge lead here look at this lively eye
musician on set point to eliminate
octave from the total but who knew your
team it was answered this whole time
everyone complaining about kuba just
back - you just pick Yoshimitsu right
back the rest of it just spit away okay
okay do it yeah that spin has been
helping them out so much listen when his
backs to the wall yeah he just has a
radar for getting away from danger on
the read of that big job right I just
think right now this flow is oh my gosh
he's he's in full control such as cocoa
killer looking I'm using he is
Oh fire look look at the boys though
he's like yeah man I did it yep and I'm
out of here
we still need to unplug it I was like
look how casually he is about it like
that looks like a heavy arcade stick god
damn I'll get thrown it's all right
which it should say sorry